Alice llegó a Francia gracias a la
gimnasia artística comenzó a practicarla
a los cinco años desde entonces es lo
que le hace olvidarse del resto del
mundo lo cual la puerta de varios clubes
en Europa el de Antony la aceptó en ese
suburbio del sur de París vive con luz
nida su mamá tras salir de Ucrania donde
quedaron su papá su hermano y amigos
estaba muy contenta porque me postulé a
varios clubes y cuando me respondieron
fue una alegría me dije Ay Por fin
Alguien contestó
es una tal Ucrania participó en varias
competencias nacionales
me siento muy feliz cada vez que voy a
entrenar me conecto con el objeto que
trabajo me interesa saber cómo debo usar
mis manos y la música es muy divertido
para mí las competencias no me gustan
mucho entre nosotras las niñas del club
pero sí las competiciones externas
cuando he trabajado bastante y puedo
mostrar todo lo que tengo
este exigente deporte le ha permitido
conocer a otras gimnastas como ella en
el club gr de Anthony se entrenan 16 de
sus compatriotas desde el año pasado
entre ellas quienes entrenadora hace
cinco meses llegó a Francia
es en verdad importante para mí poder
compartir mis conocimientos mi
experiencia con esas jóvenes
la gimnasia en Ucrania ocupa un lugar
importante para las niñas el objetivo es
obtener resultados en Francia
después de encontrar En qué club
entrenar urgía hallar una nueva casa
para alisa y su mamá viagala las
acogieron los primeros cinco meses de su
llegada
Tratamos de que todos se sientan a gusto
abrimos todos los armarios y dijimos
Esto va Aquí Esto va allá luego las
cosas fluyeron de manera muy simple muy
sencilla con mucha fraternidad estábamos
felices de poderlas acoger
es una experiencia genial maravillosa
nunca las habríamos conocido Claro que
las circunstancias no son las mejores
pero es enriquecedora a alguien Sí
si soy peor
son como mis abuelos
[Risas]
el aprendizaje del idioma francés Es una
etapa clave para integrarse cada jueves
una decena de ucranianos van a clase de
francés en este colegio desde marzo de
2022 una profesora ucraniana es la
encargada de dictarlas
[Música]
creo que puede incluso ayudar a nivel de
ánimos quizás porque yo entiendo lo que
está sucediendo en Ucrania en este
momento
y como Y cómo puedo animar a los alumnos
el resto de la semana estos alumnos van
a clase en otro colegio con estudiantes
franceses así progresan más rápido
les gusta mucho jugar Incluso en francés
Así que esos juegos lúdicos son un medio
de aprender el idioma y muy pertinente
para los estudiantes de estas edades
Cómo les fue con nosotros actores me
gustó su grupo
a sus 14 años alisa habla Además del
ucraniano ruso inglés y francés
tuve que aprender francés para poder
hacer los ejercicios con mis compañeros
de clase y con eso puedo también hablar
francés cuando mi mamá necesite así
puedo leer los documentos del médico y
demás Eso es en realidad muy importante
para poder ganar su sustento ludmila que
en su natal Ucrania se desempeñaba como
gerente aceptó trabajar como aseadora en
julio pasado obtuvo un contrato a tiempo
indefinido su motor el futuro de su hija
lo más importante para mí es que puedas
continuar con tus estudios Yo no
necesito pero tú debes seguir
vivienda trabajo escuela en un año alisa
y su mamá han logrado integrarse pero su
corazón sigue en Ucrania donde permanece
en su padre y su hermano a pesar de la
situación tratan de hablarse por
teléfono Cada día oled y sacar siguen
al león
hermana
a una sociedad
la familia Espera que sacar pueda venir
a Francia para continuar con sus
estudios cuenta con la documentación
requerida pero por la guerra Ucrania no
deja salir a ningún hombre en edad
militar
es muy triste porque nos hacen falta
queremos verlos pero no podemos ir a
verlos
a pesar de las dificultades seguimos
siendo optimistas eso es lo que hace
Nuestra fuerza ante la adversidad la
familia se mantiene unida y en contacto
incluso con la abuela que sigue en el
don vas y que de vez en cuando logra
llamar para tener noticias de los suyos